to going backwards just enough where he
can slide to his left give himself some
room to pull up for his jumper
spectacular move by Kyrie
I had some Julius Erving type spin on it
the way he was a couple of years this is
the first of a back to back for this
they're in Atlanta tomorrow night who
counted it goes higher what a tattle
what a talent can you see where he'd
jump from took the contact and where he
has to reach
oh my goodness
he has no angle he has no angle when he
lets us go what about the English we had
39 he was the League's worst a year ago
doc Rivers's incursion to go up there
with confidence
are we spitting inside
[Music]
and now you don't
43-40. Christian Thompson
carrying it from the Sprout for his
hustle Urban with a series of moves
Kyrie Irving can you even describe it
that's just beautiful basketball
you have to love it the left-handed look
at this you think he's going up with the
left
Psych on the right the stress almost did
not see that pass he just recognized it
right when he caught it Harry Urban goes
through the entire defense
Standing Ovation from this crowd
oh
[Applause]
High the game coming out of halftime
just wanted to be aggressive leave my
guys and leave it all out there on the
floor and it didn't come without it ba
wall at age 27 four-time All-Star
[Music]
got the big extension of Summer that
will start in 2019 is Irving what a move
or Kyrie Irving starting to percolate
pick and roll how about the hard Jagged
cut he gets marching and I think what
happens is everybody's watching those
things so I got to be able to coach you
and tell you when you're not getting it
done
[Applause]
speed from Smart we've seen his ability
to handle the basketball so skilled
beautiful movement transition avoiding
Caruso
look at this guy
so these are the moves he made in in the
playground now I know how to you can add
it to the list of things you need to
watch here's Kyrie Irving oh
oh okay
this yo-yo's with the ball and the
defense excellent screen set by Jared
Allen but the quickness to slice through
another two Defenders waiting on the
back side and gets past Drummond Wood's
gonna try and stunt in Jordan comes away
with a rebound a minute 14 to play in
this first half Kyrie oh in his bag
Kyrie Irving this is unbelievable to
have a guy on his back finish around the
other side of the basket
I mean just a strong take in body
control
Irving using the Drummond screen
[Applause]
nasty look at this slices
this is too pretty
that is artwork at its best and Powell
grabs a rebound that's the thing is
Charlotte was so hot
here is Irving
oh my God
that's a little electricity
[Applause]
[Music]